this is testimony to the determination
of the global community to reject this
invasion
one only needs to see the result of this
week's united nations generally general
assembly
141 countries an overwhelming majority
supported the resolution condemning
russia for its brutal invasion
only four countries out of 193 stood by
russia it was belarus north korea syria
and eritrea
president putin is increasingly isolated
in the world community
but in the face of the world's protests
putin's army carries on
bombings and missile attacks on civilian
targets are intensifying
rest are sure
the european union and the united states
will continue to stand by ukraine
and its courageous people and its
steadfast leadership
the scale of the humanitarian
catastrophe there in ukraine that is
unfolding really worries us
europe is seeing destruction and
displacement on a scale
not seen since the darkest days of the
last century
the european union as ukraine's neighbor
is sparing no effort
we're providing 500 million euros of
humanitarian aid immediately and more
will come
we're working fast to establish civil
protection hubs in poland and slovakia
and romania
and we are also doing everything we can
with international organizations and
ngos to set up humanitarian corridors
that stretch inside ukraine
desperately needed humanitarian aid must
be able to reach all parts of ukraine
and civilians must be allowed to escape
cities under siege
finally
the european union has triggered for the
first time ever
the so-called temporary protection
directive what is it
it effectively opens up residency rights
for most refugees to live and work in
the european union to have access to
health services or for example schools
for at least a year
we know that this conflict is far from
over
and to be very clear
we are ready to take further severe
measures if putin does not stop and
reverse the war he has unleashed